Here's a spoiler for you: Try as you might,
you can't please everyone.
It's something that Game of Thrones showrunners
David Benioff and D.B. Weiss have learned
the hard way, as the final season of the pop
culture phenomenon has infuriated and disappointed
legions of fans and critics around the world.
In fact, so many people were upset by the
final season that over a million viewers signed
an online petition calling for HBO to remake
all six episodes with different storylines
and a new team of writers.
So what does the cast of Game of Thrones think
about all this?
Well, Isaac Hempstead Wright, who plays the
newest king of Westeros, Bran Stark, told
The Hollywood Reporter that he for one thought
the petition was absurd.
"I saw today there's a petition to redo the
ending […] It's just absurd.
I can't even fathom it.
[...] It's ridiculous that people think they
can just demand a different ending because
they don't like it."
Hempstead Wright admitted that he took the
petition personally, in part because he just
doesn't agree with people who think the final
season was bad.
"What people were hoping for is an Avengers-esque
thing where all the superpowers are explained
and everybody comes together and there's a
big team effort.
Game of Thrones isn't like that.
It's unpredictable by nature.
[...] In my opinion, it's a great ending […] I
don't think it's some plot twist to be shocking
for the sake of shocking.
I think it's a genuine character development."
In fact, he thinks people getting angry at
the ending is just further proof of how good
the show was.
"The fact that characters are not doing what
people want them to do?
It's a good thing.
The fact that people are getting pissed off
and having a big emotional response?
That's the reason why Game of Thrones is successful.
It doesn't do what everyone wants them to
do."
Of course, the interview with Hempstead Wright
was published before the season finale aired
on Sunday, May 19.
At the time the petition was created, fans
were still infuriated over the events of the
show's penultimate episode, "The Bells," which
saw fan favorite Daenerys Targaryen go completely
mental and mass-murder tens if not hundreds
of thousands of people for what seemed like
no good reason.
The finale, though, has by and large received
kinder critical and fan reviews.
Though it didn't fully satisfy everyone, the
death of Daenerys at Jon Snow's hand, and
the subsequent crowning of Bran the Three-Eyed
Raven as king of the Six Kingdoms was met
more with resigned shrugs than blinding rage.
And at least Benioff and Weiss wrote and directed
the finale themselves, making sure that the
final responsibility for bringing the series
home rested on the right shoulders.
After all, as Ned taught Bran way back in
the series premiere,
"The man who passes the sentence should swing
the sword."
So while it's true that few fans got everything
they wanted out of the finale, the fact that
nobody's completely satisfied might actually
be a good thing.
Just ask Tyrion:
"No one is very happy, which means it's a
good compromise I suppose."
Indeed, the last episode of Game of Thrones
took some interesting turns and placed power
into the hands of a few unexpected people.
It also gave the members of the Stark family
a relatively happy ending, something nobody
could have expected after all the losses they
suffered in previous seasons.
And the divisive final season doesn't change
the fact that so many people genuinely love
the show, or that Thrones will go down in
history as one of the most popular television
series of this generation.
As the new king of Westeros said,
"If people really, really hate this season?
Then so be it.
But it's been seven or eight years of absolutely
brilliant television that captivated the world
[...] I think people will remember it as a
fabulous journey to have been a part of, no
matter their opinion on the ending."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Game of
Thrones are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.